da sind wir wieder zurück aus der
winterpause als wär kein tag vergangen
immer noch lockdown immer noch leeres
studio immer noch homeschooling also
wenn wir zusammen zählen eigentlich
alles wie vor weihnachten nur jetzt halt
mit mutanten ja eine heikle situation
einerseits endlich wieder ins events
unter 100 andererseits wer weiß wo die
ganzen mutanten rumlaufen weiß keiner
wenn es ganz blöd läuft entsteht gerade
eine art pandemie 2.0 stimmung anzahl
wir brauchen eine andere stimmung die
leute drehen ja durch lockdown und
soziale isolation haben nämlich auch
psychologische folgen mensch braucht
schließlich näher und am ende tut es
sogar ein baum denn es kommt nicht so
sehr darauf an dass da eine
zwischenmenschliche beziehung ist
sondern welche gefühle ich dabei habe
bin ich etwas umarme natürlich dann aber
bitte auch daran denken wie der baum
sich fühlt da steckt viel zu dieser
herzlich kurz danach selber gefällt doch
zurück zu den mutanten die sind wohl
deutlich ansteckender und stehen unter
verdacht sich vor allem unter jüngeren
schnell zu verbreiten heißt es ja aber
auch das ändert nichts am lockerungs
druck bei uns im land ich sage
spätestens wenn wir uns der magischen
fünfziger incidents nähern wird es
verdammt schwer für die politik den
käfig noch zu zu halten
unsere entscheidungsträger muss man
immer wieder sagen haben es halt gerade
auch nicht leicht und manchen
entscheidungsträgern merkt man auch an
schönen guten abend winfried schwarz
muss ich einfach deutlich werden man
muss nicht jede kleine differenz aufbau
das geht einfach nicht das hat doch
überhaupt keine relevanz ich muss aber
noch mal widersprechen das sind sich
alle einig das machen auch alle nicht
alles hochziehen nicht ewig so tun als
seien da schulden am berg das ist
einfach nicht der fall darf ich einmal
kurz zwischen an dem punkt nein nein
jetzt darf der land in seiner eigenen
sendung nichts mehr sagen gar nicht
schlecht
bis mitte februar läuft der aktuelle
lockdown noch und dann ja kleiner
spoiler so am 8 9 februar trifft sich
die übliche runde und legt noch einen
drauf mangels anderer ideen wie endlich
schnelltests in massen strategisch
einsetzen weil ich habe gar kein
grundsätzliches lockdown problem
es wundert mich nur schon dass unser
privatleben fast schon überreguliert
wird aber am arbeitsplatz bleibt alles
freiwillig nur appelle ach was hat
wissenschaftliche gründe auch so
arbeitgeber nur virologen haben etwas
sensationelles herausgefunden dass
koroma virus ist gar nicht überall
ansteckend es spürt instinktiv wenn
irgendwo geld verdient wird und
verzichtet dann aus respekt vor dem
bruttoinlandsprodukt auf ansteckung
dasselbe gilt für den weg zur arbeit
auch hier null gefahr brandgefährlich
dagegen sind freizeitaktivitäten wie das
besonders bei mehr als 15 kilometer
entfernung zum wohnort unsere forschung
beweist echten schutz bietet tatsächlich
nur der arbeitsplatz
deshalb arbeiten sie als ginge es um ihr
leben
ja auch wenn es wehtut sprechen wir es
bitte offen aus der ehemalige corona
streber deutschland ist zum
verhaltensauffälligen problemkind
geworden ich sag nur impfstoff man man
man impfen das vielzitierte licht am
ende des tunnels inzwischen nur noch
eine traurige funzel der
gesundheitsminister rechnet im technisch
mit noch mindestens zehn harten wochen
sicher auch für politiker ist es
natürlich die erste pandemie aber leute
die deutschen waren nochmal
organisations weltmeister effizienz
könige was ist denn hier los war und
aber die dinge die der in deutschland
gesehen haben die schnelligkeit unseres
handelns lässt sehr zu wünschen übrig ja
das stimmt hat sie sich gerade selbst
ihr abgangszeugnis geschrieben oder was
war das wer hat denn die letzten 16
jahre regiert als unter anderem die
gesundheitsämter kaputt gespart wurden
müsste man mal googeln wer das war
beim thema digitalisierte verwaltung
liegen wir deutschen unter eu schnitt
alle deutschen gesundheitsämter sollten
längst mit der software sommers arbeiten
aktuell ist es gerade mal ein drittel
der ämter fröhliches weiter wachsen sagt
ich da zum vergleich in nigeria kommt
sommer seit 2009 10 flächendeckend zum
einsatz oder hier die legendäre deutsche
leitkultur zu viel bürokratie auch teil
unseres problems sie hier immer noch
stoppt nur corona helfen kann doch nicht
sein
wir schaffen es zwar nicht die menschen
in altenheimen zu schützen immer noch
nicht aber dafür regeln wir das
blumenläden in niedersachsen nicht
öffnen dürfen es sei denn sie verkaufen
lebensmittel
das führt dann schon mal zu solch
skurrilen szenen primär möglich gerne ja
nur leider geht das im moment nicht
können die nur auf telefonische
vorbestellung verkaufen die blut ja geht
im moment leider nicht anders das heißt
wenn sie jetzt raus gehen würden und
anrufen würden dann würde ich ihnen die
zusammen packen also ich anrufen von
draußen ja klar
so logisch deswegen stelle ich meine
blumen ja nur noch bei amazon prime also
weniger bürokratie mehr tempo nicht das
noch mal gern auch mehr impfstoff man
selbst bei den über 80 jährigen zieht
sich das impfen noch bis weit in den
april
und dann liefert astrazeneca auch noch
viel zu wenig von seinem komischen 65 im
stoff ist eine unverschämtheit
und warum bitte hat die eu letztes jahr
so wenig und so spät bestellt und was
immer diskutiert wird ist die frage wie
viel impfstoff hat ihr bestellt das ist
wirklich ehrlich gesagt interessant auch
so ehrlich gesagt finde ich das total
interessant
hätten wir nämlich von jedem der sechs
vielversprechendsten impfstoffe letzten
sommer auf verdacht genug für 60 prozent
der eu bürger bestellt hätte das rund 36
milliarden euro gekostet
experten schätzen so viel wie ein tag
lockdown in europa klassischer fall von
am falschen ende gespart würde ich sagen
dann hätten die firmen nämlich auch
rechtzeitig mehr produktionsanlagen
bauen können ja dafür haben sie und ihre
leute beim dosen kauf aber erfolgreich
gefeilt um mit dem so gesparten geld
können wir jetzt ja grenze kaufen oder
mehr kerzen zum ins fenster stellen wo
ist sie hin die ganze dezember euphorie
today ist ein tumor wachsen ergänzt
kapitän ist beginning of the european
junior people with the taking gewachsen
in essens in rom in helsinki in sofia
but not in recklinghausen herne bottrop
ii kostet nrw ist schon wieder impfstoff
klar
klar war es richtig als eu gemeinsam zu
verhandeln aber man hätte es ja trotzdem
anders und besser machen können und
selbst das bisschen impfstoff dass wir
haben in deutschland kriegen wir nicht
unter die leute und zwar wegen
kleinstaaterei
das bundesland macht natürlich sein
eigenes einladungsmanagement in manchen
brechen die telefonhotlines zusammen in
andern die online plattform in wieder
anderen beides und nur mal als kleiner
tipp wenn man über 80-jährige einlädt
sollte man ihre sprache sprechen
gestern kommt per sms ein link zur
online registrierung
bitte aktivieren sie ihren im schlichten
einfach indem sie folgende link
superstars ist öffnen http www.im das
ist deutschland die gesundheitsämter
dürfen noch faxen aber europa muss ins
darknet vielen dank auch schauen wir
nach vorne hilft ja nichts die spannende
frage lautet wie verteilt man die paar
fläschchen die wir jetzt haben gerecht
mein vorschlag wir erklären das mit
einer klassischen game show super idee
olli und wo sollte das laufen wenn nicht
bei deutschlands risikogruppen sender
numero uno ihrem zdf wir spielen jetzt
jeden abend eine runde
[Musik]
die mega show zur deutschen imst blamage
zwei kandidaten über 80 aber nur einer
wird geimpft horst wohnt im sauerland
und kämpft seit tagen online um einen
impftermin obwohl es in seinem dorf gar
kein internet gibt werners frau
verbietet ihm ins netz zu gehen weil er
sich da schon drei neue frauen aus
russland bestellt hat runde 1 horst und
werner bitte holt jetzt eure smartphones
raus okay mein gott vergessen wir die
smartphones jeder kriegt einen laptop
und hier kommt eure challenge geht auf
die homepage des gesundheitsamtes und
ladet euch die termin app herunter dann
öffnet ihr den link in der einladung
smail für das im vorgespräch und scannt
den qr-code aber achtung beim einloggen
die zwei-faktor-authentifizierung nicht
vergessen
die zeit läuft
nehme eine na das sind doch schon mal 0
punkte für beide läuft ja super werner
sieht seinen enkel joker
da kommt auch schon ein genervter enkel
und hilft beim app runterladen ranke
kevin tolly du merkst diese schau ist
nervenkitzel pur plus ihre actionspiele
zum beispiel müssen horst und werner ihr
impfzentrum erstmal finden im
gewerbegebiet am arsch der welt das kann
tage dauern
hallo im zentrum will nach hause hama
und am ende unser großes finalspiel
horst und werner wir haben eine impf
dosen da ganz oben an der studiodecke
versteckt hier sind eure kletterseile
wer zuerst wird geimpft der andere macht
ein dummes gesicht co
das alles und auch morgen
jeden abend bei
carolin kebekus ja kein wunder dass
pandemie müdigkeit jetzt schon das wort
des jahres ist die leute sind durch
haben sie bestimmt gewesen
psychotherapeuten haben keine termine
mehr frei reden darüber mit unserem
heute-show pandemie coach mit olaf
schubert schön dass du da bist ja hallo
geregelt du das im alltag mit deiner
familie wie hältst du die und die vielen
kinder bei laune
klare regeln und feste strukturen ja
also ich weiß dass das für viele
altmodisch klingt aber ich bin da auch
so ein kleiner feldwebel ja also strikt
das programm 16 uhr aufstehen dann
frühstück und dann sofort homeschooling
und zur belohnung nach dem homeschooling
dann dürfen die kinder dem vater becken
und dann machen wir was zusammen also
zum beispiel feierabend oder je nach dem
ja und die kleinkinder die gehen
natürlich in die kita klar als meine das
nicht direkt gewünscht aber
ich meine ich kann ja zu hause auch nur
notbetreuung anbieten
ziemlich anja und das notbetreuung
können die in der kita bessert ist die
notbetreuung nötiger würde ich sagen
jetzt wurden uns bürgern ja im verlauf
der letzten wochen mehrmals hoffnungen
gemacht und dann wieder enttäuscht im
sinne von so jetzt noch kurz den
november durchhalten jetzt noch kurz im
dezember den januar den februar
was könnte die politik in der
kommunikation besser man sieht also auch
in der politik ist die homöopathie auf
dem vormarsch also schlechte nachrichten
in kleinen dosen jedoch schlechte
nachrichten bleiben schlechte
nachrichten ja ich meine werden die
besser wenn jetzt von einem topmodel
halbnackt im bikini wir verkündet werden
das klavier aber dann sind wir schon
wieder in der debatte
also ich glaube die politik kann nur
eins die muss zwischendurch immer mal
super stimmungsrakete nab hören die
leute die leute irgendwie ja wieder in
stimmung bringen also eben am ende des
horizonts ist ein tunnel oder wenn nicht
dann jetzt ja alles hat ein ende nur
corona nicht rund bei uns also fazit
wenn ein die jauche bis zum hals steht
dann den kopf nicht hängen lassen
ja man hat natürlich jetzt gerade
beobachtet durch den dauer lockt bauen
werden viele leute unvorsichtiger ist
auch gar keinen vorwurf das gehirn ist
nicht für dauer- alarmismus gemacht wie
bringe ich die menschen dazu sich
trotzdem weiter an die berühmten
berühmten aha regeln zu halten
ich hab das dahingehend verinnerlicht
das sind für mich von quasi religiöse
handlungen also das ist auch eine art
dreieinigkeit nenne ich das ja also ich
bewege mich zwischen bett computer und
bier und zurück das ist ein kreislauf
aber dreieckig so und durch diese
isolation vermeide ich den kontakt mit
anderen menschen und ich vermeide sogar
den kontakt mit mir ja also einmal habe
ich mich berührt aus versehen hat in der
maske auf
aber halt wirklich nur mit dem
ellenbogen und sich nichts passiert habe
ich nachher getestet also nicht
schwanger auf gottseidank um einen alten
spruch aus seiner ehemaligen heimat ddr
zu zitieren das war nicht alles schlecht
auch im lockdown war nicht alles
schlecht wenn man überlegt wenn man
liest mehr man holt sie alten
brettspiele raus man man kocht zusammen
jeden tag weil was könnte positives
bleiben ich bedauere das sehr dass diese
positiven aspekte so hinten überfallen
also zb die umweltaspekte ja sauberere
luft das war in china wirklich messbar
es gab in china kinder die haben zum
ersten mal ihre eltern gesehen ja auch
wir sind unseren kindern näher gekommen
ja und sei es noch mit der flachen hand
beim homeschooling also viele
kleinigkeiten
man kann zum beispiel wieder mal den
keller aufräumen
ja ich bin dort runter ich habe zeug
wiederentdeckt wusste gar nicht mehr
dass wir das gehört ich habe massenhaft
zeug in die mülltonne gestoppt dann kam
der nachbar wieder rausgeholt werden
meint es mehrere sein keller also so
viele kleinigkeiten zum beispiel man
verliert durch eine chronische infektion
den geruchssinn
ja das wird viele ehen retten gerade
jetzt im winter man verliert den
geschmackssinn toll als meine freundin
oder frau glaube ich die krone hatte da
habe ich habe jeden abend etwas leckeres
gekocht und aus dem ganzen überlagerten
konservendosen die im keller gefunden
habe ich denke dass alles wird man wenn
es dabei ist ja vermissen wahrscheinlich
vielen dank olaf schubert
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
mime hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und sie
töten - wollt dann abonniert jetzt den
kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]